if a 20 might not be the series at
absolute peak form Volta isn't the
revolution it perhaps could have been
and career mode still feels
underdeveloped but modern FIFA is such a
broad deep and complete offering that it
remains a must buy for football fans
[Music]
[Applause]
on the pitch fever 20 is remarkably
similar to last year there are some
welcome improvements like more natural
first touches and more satisfying ball
physics but things feel very similar to
FIFA 19 once you walk out at the tunnel
set-pieces though have received a bit of
a makeover specifically direct free
kicks and penalties in a throwback to
the halcyon days of FIFA 2003 both now
have you aim a reticle where you want to
place the ball then like with last
year's time finishing you'll need to
press shoot again at the right time
while also adding curve if you wish both
take time to get used to but they offer
greater depth and satisfaction when you
smack one into the top corner FIFA
twenties biggest new mode is of course
Valter football bringing street soccer
to the main series for the first time
you control a squad of superstars aiming
to become the world's best in a journey
that takes you around the globe matches
are shorter and more chaotic than a
standard 11 a side game and they feel
sufficiently different and entertaining
to become a worthwhile staple in FIFA's
roster of modes fancier tricks and
flicks and simplified tactics make it a
mode that feels a little more focused on
fun but don't expect the depth FIFA
Street gave us all those years ago there
are no game breakers shots here and it's
not as easy to utterly humiliate your
opponent without rageous nutmegs and
rainbow flicks instead volta focuses on
the culture of street soccer where the
language and atmosphere are more relaxed
more expressive and more open to
customization the voltar store and
challenges both unlocked new gear and
combined with the ability to play
against online human opponents in Volta
league these mean voltar has more
lasting appeal than the mode it replaces
the journey for those who miss cutscenes
and dialogue choices there's a vault a
story it's world tour structure is
compelling and it's real-world locations
well realised with unique personalities
and play styles of their own however the
characters you share your travels with
are so irritating and the writing so
aggressively how do you do fellow kids
it becomes a bit of a chore to play
other oddities such as inexplicably
needing to play the same opponent over
and over every squad having the exact
same goalkeeper and some basic
positioning errors mean voltar comes
across as a mode that feels
simultaneously long-lasting and
half-baked career mode is FIFA's other
main single-player offering and it comes
with a ruff of new features proper
conversations between manager and
players are finally possible for example
players will come to you to complain or
to thank you about their game time as
they have for many years but you now
have the opportunity to reply with the
aim to keep their morale and performance
levels high the system is shallow with
the morale bar seemingly the only
variable you can affect a messages still
repeat themselves with the same old
typos but it is at least a little more
interactive than the stack
an old email system similarly pre and
post match press conferences have been
overhauled again the objective here is
to maintain your team's morale and again
there isn't much more to it but it is
more visually and intellectually
stimulating than a simple menu screen as
it was before the final big new feature
dynamic player potential means players
potential ratings now change based on
your treatment of them the move will
please career mode ultras but in
practice it makes little difference to
anybody but the most committed of
players disappointingly despite all the
changes career mode still feels a little
bare-bones and it still contains a
number of inaccuracies the transfer
window ends too late for English clubs
for instance while var and short goal
kicks are yet to be introduced into FIFA
at all transfer negotiations scouting
and youth setups are the same for yet
another year in a row career mode has
taken some steps forward this year but a
revolution is needed Ultimate Team
continues its expansion and is now
bigger and better than ever there's a
fortnight battle pass type system called
[ __ ] seasons which is essentially an
expansion of the existing daily and
weekly challenges with new tasks you can
work towards over multiple weeks or the
entire year it all has another way to be
rewarded and yet another objective to
work towards with a new casual mode
called [ __ ] friendlies also introduced
Ultimate Team is now as compelling and a
complete as ever and I'm horribly
obsessed once again flawed and iterative
but comforting complete and compelling
FIFA 20 is as frustrating and as
essential as ever the journey and FIFA
Street will continue to be missed but
despite its flaws
Valter offers a genuinely different
option for those who want to dip in and
out across FIFA's selection of game
types our Ultimate Team continues its
route to world domination it's just a
shame career mode continues to stagnate
even if EA has finally remembered that
it exists
[Applause]
[Music]
you